believe it or not your next iPhone or
even your MacBook like this one could be
coming with an Intel chip now you
probably don't believe me but in this
video I am going to prove it to you
let's get started now over a year ago
Intel CEO Pat gelsinger said that he
hopes to win back apple as a chip
customer one day that's of course
because Apple dished Intel and went with
their own Apple silicon chips on their
MacBooks just like they do for their
iPhones but I do think Intel is going to
be right and they're going to win them
back now back then even I was laughing
at Intel saying there's no way that was
gonna happen I made a bunch of videos
saying that intel was done x86 was
screwed but I think I might be wrong let
me show you why just the other day Apple
CEO Tim Cook said that they are going to
be sourcing chips from Arizona starting
in
2024. not only that but Mark German the
Top Apple leaker also said that they
could be sourcing chips from Europe in
2024 and the main point is to diversify
the supply chain now if you don't know
why Apple would do that well it's
because China is becoming kind of a
problem for Apple which Mark German
pointed out way back in May Apple's over
dependence on China keeps creating new
problems for the iPhone maker and
recently those problems have been
getting even worse like apple had to
limit the airdrop file sharing feature
on iPhones in China because they were
used by protesters to spread images to
other iPhone users which is kind of
weird and honestly a little bit sus now
even worse Apple said that the covid
lockdowns at Foxconn and China are going
to be slowing iPhone 14 pro and iPhone
14 pro Max output and if you don't know
what went on in those Factory is well
basically the workers were literally
fleeing running away from foxconn's
largest iPhone Factory after a really
bad lockdown and because of that apple
had to come out and make a statement
saying that they now expect lower iPhone
14 pro and pro Max shipments than
previously anticipated and customers
will experience longer wait times to
receive their new products which is
really bad news and guess what just
broke out if you order an iPhone right
now today it is unlikely to arrive in
time for Christmas in the US that was
actually yesterday but check out today
yep iPhone 14 pro models are officially
sold out you will not get one until
December
27th which I don't think that's ever
happened before so if you're wondering
why apple is looking to get some chips
from Arizona starting in 2024 that is
basically why but that's only half the
story it unfortunately could get worse
some users were saying on Twitter that
apple is essentially preparing for a
potential invasion of Taiwan which is
really scary to see but it looks like
apple is basically pulling out of China
as quickly as they can trying to
diversify that supply chain find other
sources just in case that happens
because tsmc in Taiwan is supplying
basically all of Apple's chips and your
iPhone your Mac basically everything and
replacing that output would take years
and making things even worse Ken Griffin
recently said let's be clear if we lose
access to Taiwanese semiconductors that
hit to US GDP is probably on an order of
magnitude of five to ten percent it's an
immediate Great Depression so that is
the main main reason Apple needs to find
some other places to Source their chips
now immediately the first thing that
comes to mind is that apple is going to
use tsmc's brand new plant in Arizona
that is going to be going up running in
2024. that's what I personally expected
but I'm going to talk about why it could
actually be Intel that apple is looking
at but before I get into how apple is
going to expand their supply chain let's
talk about how you can expand your
living room by turning a regular TV into
a fully immersive experience with our
Channel partner Lightning's new fantasy
plus kit by extending the colors in
action far beyond just the screen this
works great for music and movies since
it supports Dolby vision and HDR 10 plus
as well as for gaming with support for
4K 60 where many similar price
competitors can only do 1080p the full
kit price is incredible at 299 dollars
whereas a matching Hue sync kit that
supports the same formats comes in at
over nine hundred dollars it's also
incredibly easy to set up you just peel
and stick the light strip around your TV
and then download the app to sync it up
they have multiple modes and options so
you can use the app and customize
however you like best and it's voice
compatible with Amazon Alexa Google
assistant and smart things and even
better lightning is giving the biggest
discount of the Year 20 off on all
lightning products for Black Friday and
Cyber Monday so check the link in the
description below to stay tuned now
getting back to why I think apple is not
going to be solely relying on tsmc and
probably going for Intel this is the
reason right here tsmc's Fab that
they're opening in Arizona is actually a
five nanometer node chip Fab and that
right there is a massive problem because
was next year's M3 chips for Max and a17
chip for the iPhone 15 Pro Models are
going to be using tsmc's second
generation three nanometer process yes
they're jumping to three nanometer while
the factory in Arizona is only going to
be five nanometer in 2024 when we're
already going to be expecting the a18
share so that basically makes that brand
new tsmc Arizona Fab useless for Apple's
new iPhones especially the high-end ones
now on the positive side there are some
reports that apple and tsmc are working
together to move three nanometer chip
production to the United States which is
great but check out this little caveat
it's looking like it's going to be until
2025 when those three nanometer chips
are going to be available to be made in
the states which unfortunately is when
Apple is expected to use two nanometer
chips and the iPhone 17 pro series of
course coming from tsmc on the island of
Taiwan assuming that by that time no
Invasion happens and making things even
worse check out this article tsmc
Arizona plans are mostly PR for Apple
suggests Bloomberg and the main point is
that the new site in Arizona the brand
new Fab is only going to be producing
about 20 000 Wafers of silicon chips per
month that's less than 1.6 percent of
the 1.3 million that tsmc currently
churns out monthly in Taiwan and even if
they add another Arizona plant as
expected the U.S facility will be
nowhere near able to fill Apple's total
orders and because of that this leads us
to speculation that it's actually going
to be Intel's latest Fab that apple is
is going to be using from Arizona check
out this tweet from whiteaken I don't
know who that is but check it out the
only Leading Edge Arizona Fab in 2024
will be owned by Intel which is their
28a node not tsmc with their five
nanometer known congrats on the ifs win
at Pat gelsinger yes I think that is
actually correct because Intel is going
to have a more sophisticated and more
advanced node in 2024 and Apple's
probably going to want to use that
compared to those older five nanometer
chips so way back a year ago when
everybody was laughing at Intel CEO
saying that he wants to win back Apple
by making better chips than Apple well
it looks like Intel can actually be
correct and even a couple weeks ago we
got some reports from Nikkei Asia how
Intel plans to rival tsmc and Samsung as
a chip sub supplier and we of course
know tsmc's number one client which is
Apple so Intel wants to take some of
tsmc's business and I think Apple's
gonna do it and if you didn't already
know Intel announced their road map to
2025 with all of the different process
nodes going all the way down to 18 a
which is basically equivalent to 2
nanometer tsmc with 20a being equivalent
to 3 nanometer which will be coming in
2024 so because of that it's basically
going to be irresistible to Apple to use
those Fabs in Arizona and I think the
main point that you should probably take
away is that when Tim Cook made this
announcement he did not specify which
Fab or company it would be he just said
we're getting chips from Arizona he
never said Arizona's tsmc he left that
possibility open and the main point that
I want to make is that in the case that
that Taiwan actually does get invaded
and apple loses tsmc's chip Supply Apple
will literally be sourcing chips from
every possible Fab in the world of
course including Intel but the problem
is that literally every other company is
going to be doing the same thing because
tsmc produced the majority of the
world's chips and if that gets cut off
it's gonna be bad just like Ken Griffin
said it's going to be an immediate Great
Depression so because of that Apple has
no choice they're gonna have to go and
diversify their supply chain they're
gonna have to swallow their pride and go
for some of those nice Intel 28 chips
and I think that this article from
patently Apple makes a pretty good point
while Intel will also have a new plant
in Arizona it's unlikely that Apple will
shift away from tsmc unless unforeseen
political Mayhem happens to break out in
Taiwan then again why didn't cook just
confirm that it's tsmc so based on that
right there if things end up getting
worse with the whole U.S China politics
situation there's a good chance that
your next iPhone or your next Mac or
MacBook could be coming out of an Intel
Fab yes that could likely happen so with
that said if you completely disagree
with what I'm saying in this video let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed it click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]